l'homme idéal à 27 ans sylvie en a vu de
toutes les couleurs elle a été agressée
en sang et elle a subi la violence de
ces conjoints ses souvenirs font
frissonner une fracture à mon choix je
me se ramasserait leur part parce
quelqu'un que j'ai accouché mois
j'accouchais pas avec un beau visage
j'avais un équipement se la joue parce
qu'évidemment bat la veille marie elle a
52 ans elle vient d'une communauté de la
côte nord elle a tout abandonné il ya
six mois pour la sécurité d'un refuge
pour femmes violentées à des centaines
de kilomètres de chez elle
voir quelqu'un derrière la porte avec un
outil assez anglais assez de faire
passer à travers la fenêtre l'eau avec
mon fils père alcoolique mère malade
conjoint violent abuseurs sa vie a été
une succession d'agressions
j'avais de la difficulté aussi aller
chercher de l'aide parce que c'est un le
réseau est très petit je pouvais je
pouvais retrouver ma belle soeur qui
travaille à telle place m'a causé natale
place tout le monde se connaît dans sa
communauté qui compte 1400 âmes
même les policiers dit elles ne font
rien pourquoi c'est moi qui dois quitter
pourquoi c'est moi qui dois souffrir
pourquoi c'est moi qui doit laisser ses
enfants quand lui se prend même
librement dans la communauté
elle espère un jour retourner chez elle
mais pour cela les choses devront
changer dans sa communauté et font
partie de la solution aussi les uns
parce que je pense qu'il faut que
parlent les langues doivent se délier
dit elle
mais les fans doivent aussi mieux
connaître leurs droits
les gens ne savent port qui ont recourt
aussi à une justice parce qu'on voit on
voit la justice avec mes pieds info
d'injustice qui vont punir ou qui vont
prendre nos enfants elle estime
toutefois que plus de 80% des femmes
autochtones subissent des violences
partout au québec qu'on peut avancer
et plus aborder maintenant la prise de
solutions les démarches on devrait faire
pour atténuer ses formes de vue l
instant une commission parlementaire est
un point de départ et elle doit se tenir
dans le respect des traditions
autochtones
on peut pas passer à côté il y aura une
situation précise de violence aigus le
projet est dans les cartons depuis deux
ans mais le dossier a évolué lentement
les communautés autochtones sont
maintenant prêtes et le premier ministre
tient à la tenue de cette commission
les premières audiences pourraient avoir
lieu avant noël
est ce qu'on parle d'espoir pour ces
femmes de j pop moderne beauport me
pozzi aubin ce genre d'homme blue que tu
devrais aimer
déjà j'avais été détruits c'est qu'elle
me fait me faire détruire encore plus
bête pour moi c'était quelque chose
d'anormal
elle travaille fort pour reprendre leur
vie en main très loin des leurs
maintenant je vais tout un homme j'ai
moins pas mais j'ai toujours une pensée
pour cette femme
ces femmes là qui sont encore chez elles
dans leur maison qui vivent de la
violence aussi ici martin biron radio
canada québec